we could call out the hypocrisy all the
time right we could do it forever but it
would not be enough so what would be
enough to get us out of that slow
descent to hell i'm always talking about
well you know what it is
it's conviction
it's saying what you believe and saying
it clearly it's action doing something
about it and occasionally it's comedy
right making fun of these people so that
you can show people what the truth is so
where is that happening people well yeah
it's happening right here in the free
state of florida
here is governor ron desantis
sharing his thoughts on joe biden's
speech
well i thought it was one of the most
disgusting speeches an american
president has ever given he ran as being
a unifier and he's basically saying to
the vast majority of the country that
disapproves of him
that they're effectively a threat to the
republic he dotters he lashes out
but at the end of the day his policies
are why there's so much opposition to
him he came in and he opened the border
and we've seen what a disaster that's
been he kneecapped american energy we've
seen how that's hurt millions and
millions of people across our country
they've inflated the currency we have
one of the worst inflations we've had in
over 40 years so of course people are
going to be upset at all the wreckage
that he's left in his wake he is the
american nero he's a failed leader and i
think that he is doing this because he's
trying to energize his base to fend off
a real butt whip in this november
that's what you do you state your case
clearly with facts so i want to address
the three things the three specific
bullet points that governor desantis
said there and let's just compare
reality versus what joe biden is talking
about so first off ron desantis calls
him out on the border well we know you
guys know we've covered it many times
here we have had more border crossings
in a shorter period of time than any
other point in american history
certainly american modern history and we
know that the democrats basically want
it right and when trump tried to do
something about it he was called a
racist so
then what happens is they get all these
illegals here they go to these
democrat-run cities like new york and dc
and then what happens their social
services start collapsing and then the
mayors like muriel bowser in dc is very
upset because her homeless shelters
which are pretty packed anyway because
of her policies are now doubly packed
because they've got a bunch of illegal
immigrants there well what happens when
you send these illegal immigrants who
should not be in this country
to places like florida we bus them to dc
you gotta love it it's actually quite
spectacular so of course ron desantis
clearly is saying the truth you guys
open the border people are pissed about
it just look what's going on with voting
the latino vote in texas which is now
going further and further to the right
and to conservatives because they've had
it with illegal immigrants the people
who came here legally then energy well
we know this we know this what was the
first thing that joe biden did in
essence you know one of his day one
things when he became president canceled
the keystone xl pipeline they are
intentionally they're telling us that we
are intentionally trying to destroy
fossil fuels we want all of you schmucks
to buy electric cars we don't care how
expensive they are go out and get an
electric car that's what gay pete said
and then of course inflation well you
spend crazy amounts you put in these
crazy bills all of this lunacy money you
just print endlessly and then i'm not a
mathemagician but then the value of
money goes down inflation goes up that's
how it works so ronda sanders clearly
states all of those things what's also
interesting about that is
i wonder what joe biden would say about
ron desantis whether he's a dark magger
republican or not now desantis is a guy
who has run this state extremely well
competently gotten critical race theory
out of our schools getting rid of the
gender nonsense our our restaurants and
our economy here absolutely packed
everywhere you go you can feel the
spirit of freedom and of life and you
don't see masks anywhere and all of that
stuff right so is that a good enough
republican for for joe biden um i think
not i think not and i think we'll see
more of that coming but okay so ron de
santa lays out
truth well what else what also should
you do you've got to have conviction you
have to actually fight and do things
because the monster and the machine is
not going to stop uh here in this case
uh here's desantis actually doing
something while biden's fda is cracking
down on
us
after 630 days you know we still sit
here waiting for an answer and so it's
our view that we've waited long enough
and so today we're taking action the
state of florida has now filed a lawsuit
against the fda
they have unlawfully withheld and
unreasonably delayed approval of
florida's program and we think this
violates federal law so we're
damn straight man yeah you sue the
federal government when they don't do
what they're supposed to do or when they
actually overstep what they're supposed
to do which in this case they're they're
often doing both right uh and then
what's the other way you do this so okay
you call it out
then you fight and you also just mock
the [ __ ] out of these people because
that's exactly what they're worthy of
with
with biden
you think of a guy
staring into the teleprompter like a
deer in a headlights
end of quote repeat the line
now i i must say
he did test positive for covid and i
want to on behalf of the state of
florida
wish president biden a speedy recovery
from covet
and i also want to wish the united
states of america a speedy recovery from
joe biden
all right there you go a little humor
related to all of this that's good and
then you know what happens if you state
your case clearly if you have conviction
and you fight if you do a little humor
every now and again you know what
happens people start seeing it they
start seeing it and they start flocking
to the places where truth still exists
where freedom still exists and they
start leaving the places where the lies
and big government and the endless suck
of your money and your attention are all
happening
you